yeah that's literally what it takes me
like even Eckhart Tolle babe I know we
love him yeah but the guys foolish [ __ ]
yes Chopra is a pretty awful [ __ ] yeah
yeah well I'll tell you why I know
Deepak Chopra is a full of [ __ ] and it
broke my heart because you know he you
know he had his own Center and La Jolla
where I lived and I ran into a couple of
waiters you know just front when I was
living down there and they said oh yeah
he comes to a restaurant and he doesn't
tip to me though yeah to me is if any
somebody doesn't tip well there's some
part of the they just there's a
selfishness or something about them
that's not they're not generous or you
know they don't get their so
disconnected to the working class they
don't know what it's like do waiting
tables I think is the one of the hardest
[ __ ] job everybody should have to
wait to yes yeah yeah because have you
used to do a row yeah for yeah yeah
right and I kind of give or miss it you
mean be slammed yeah be slammed back and
break some he's like table for Tina did
never get the Glock and Baba yeah I love
that [ __ ] like you were like oh man like
spinning all this plate I love that Wow
well I mean like it's I know now looking
back it was a it's rose-colored glasses
like that was fun to have like a
community and my take your 30 minute
break and like have two margaritas at
the bar and then yeah I'm very much
happier now and but like there's
something about it that's very
romanticized struggle I really room yeah
yeah me too yeah when you're when you
have like 12 sections and table number
eight goes can we get some ketchup and
then you're getting you're out to get
ketchup then but then to other table
stop you can I get eyes we don't have a
spoon right now you have three things
right but then now food is coming for a
different table and you could see it on
the thing right and now you're running
around like a [ __ ] madman and it
doesn't let up it never lets it never
lets up right it was like a they were
like what we do now is hard to define
success or not right that it's
successful if you get them
they're orange chicken or whatever it
was you were serving them what's up
what's up oh I just a random fella I'm
just saying though why orange chicken oh
okay yeah yeah so you bring them General
Tso's chicken
I just and then you're laughing a little
too hard on that and I like it I like
what you're doing but this is that the
thing is is that this is this that I
served American food go ahead where do
you work
Brockton Villa it was in La Jolla was at
a Cove this is the high like San Diego
right not in Beijing not that low we're
saying I did it okay now you're right
can we cut that way yeah I served at
PJ's pizzeria Wow macaroni grill and
then what's that big place in the
Beverly Center it's like no it's like
big do you remember what it was called
Grand Lux Cafe oh look there panting how
long fancy for like a full year and a
half okay I go to the Grand Lux in Vegas
it's a nice cheese hey Pat yeah Saturday
the Cheesecake Factory do you want to
know why Grand Lux Cafe exist because
Cheesecake Factory is so popular but
Cheesecake Factory had this contract
with whatever was like Caesars I think
that they could not open a second seat
Cheesecake Factory within 10 miles but
they were so popular so they made a new
restaurant concept called grandma's cafe
the same exact thing the menus huge the
servings are [ __ ] here yeah yeah and
they were like we're just gonna do
something slightly different and then be
while they successful - and grandmas
cafe has never closed in it's a 24-hour
restaurant they have fryers that have
never ever been not frying food since
the day they of the Sharks yeah sharks
yes a guy with
Highschool with Kevin shul one day he
bragged to me because he does like he
works at a place where they they do
walls that they they draw on walls and
his art and he goes you know we did the
lines on the Grand Lux Cafe I really
make a little curtain lines like the
drawing and I go I don't give a [ __ ]
it's very fine work it is would you
[ __ ] brag about that you write like
articles about the inside of Cheesecake
factories how they do yeah I think
that's a big missing out then it's like
a mishmash of everything in like the
Renaissance period mashup like they
forget like hand blown glass from Italy
yeah they're like really and also when
you work there like you're getting
trained by a corporate trainer who's
like this is the best restaurant in the
world yeah you're in but it's so funny
that you wouldn't because I don't see
you because I feel like there is an edge
to you like I mean not that you're
bitter but there is an edge to you that
I just can't see you waiting tables
really did you ever snap no I'm Harrison
ahead I waited tables I delivered pizzas
like I was service industry guy Wow that
was way into it but there was one so I
had to work at Grand Lux Cafe at the
Cheesecake Factory in Beverly Center on
New Year's Day and I didn't know my job
viously do not want to but it's a very
like it's like high-end casual it's very
weird so you have to press your shirt so
I woke up I crashed on my buddy's house
I woke up at like 9:00 in the morning to
go do the breakfast shift and I was
[ __ ] hungover and my buddies were
like didn't after work so just like
ripping bongs and like watching football
and I pressed a shirt I shaved and to be
sure I never shaved yeah I was like
cleanly shade I pressed this shirt like
I brought starch spray like I was really
doing work right yeah and then they're
like we'll hit a bowl and I like I
smoked a little bit of weed and I was
like ah ha ha and they were just like
have fun at work
and I stepped outside and rained the
night before and I came up with this
plan which is if I just jump into mud
like I'm fully prepared if I fall into
mud and show up to work
covered in mud they're gonna send me
home today I'm sick they're gonna like
your hungover coming to work or you're
fired
Wow I show up like I'm here my shirt is
pressed I'm covered in [ __ ] mud what
do you want to do they're gonna have to
be like oh my god were so sorry go home
yeah so I went outside the house and
just dove into mud yeah yeah it was very
funny there was like this is perfect
your friends oh yeah yeah we were like
talking about the right angle to go in
and then I'm just like driving to work
covered in mud like just laughs and like
I'm the smartest guy in the world and I
show up in my the manager goes holy [ __ ]
what happened he what's going on your
HUD I said yeah I was parking over there
and I was running kind of running a
little late and I was running and I
tripped on this little fence and I fell
into mud and he goes there's no yards
around here is this not there's no like
where did you fall into mud it's like
the middle of lost
there's no yeah it's all concrete Oh
freeze and I don't know what to say any
goes I'm kidding man that sucks and he
passed me on the back you know just give
you a bus or uniform you can work in
that oh no you know to me that doesn't
even sound like it would [ __ ] well it
sounds like a totally work how can you
say you can't imagine huh if you are
limped in right but dirty clothing it's
like oh we'll find something for ya okay
we're in a mall right code hmm we're in
a mall there's a I know okay well I was
um I was 38 at the time here's another
one say is is that there is nothing more
satisfying then working at a restaurant
doing a slammed shift right and then
afterwards no matter how much are making
tip wise when you leave like a she
smokes cigarettes and after my shift I
used to go to the cove
after a long [ __ ] up day
and just sit there and smoke a cigarette
and just thank God it's over you know so
I worked my ass off yeah to make this
hundred dollars right in my pocket but
that was like I don't know it's like why
hue huge and how satisfying I don't feel
like that in show biz I know right it's
talking about this room I'm not really
like romanticize struggle and like you
have something in your hand at the end
of the day yeah and you go to the bar
and you're like hey here's your tip out
thirty bucks
have a go in like you feel like you're a
kingpin it's so yeah everybody hates
their job nobody wants to be there and
like well [ __ ] on the customers and like
you know you you're doing it the best
job you can nobody's like spitting in
food every us things like you spin food
but never [ __ ] ever have I'll never
have it okay that's not sure he like
ground cockroaches and no no I
oh yeah we had a cockroach's in the
expressos renderer and certainly yes or
the beans and the cockroaches would like
you know and the new isn't put the hot
steam into the talking about snowpiercer
yeah that's again I'm sorry it's a
perfect protein yeah but there isn't and
here's another reason why butter coffee
yeah well why it felt good is because
you know I'm not lazy you know when you
do it no no not when I gave a Broadway
table and I used to be slammed and I
will sit there on the cove and smoke a
cigarette in my head is like you you're
you you manned up you showed up you
worked hard you clocked and clocked out
and you made this money that you earned
and there is a sense that's all I'm
saying
[ __ ] yet now I'm so lazy you know and
you're on set playing video games yeah
yeah I just you know I like be on a game
like the game I'm playing
and it'll a special offer you get three
knives and like you know a thing for $50
like it yeah i buy it you know then pam
has to pull you aside to be like come on
man all right don't be waiting tables
yeah I know but you know what there is a
you and I are similar in that way I miss
it a little bit I do Mitch I like the
curve
robbery that comes with it I like them
we're all in the [ __ ] I got to cover
your shift cuz you're gonna cover my
shift like I like that community I like
a community yeah but what is it like now
it's none of that right now you show up
put makeup on your face I'm not that I'm
no Bobby Lee I'm not that big like I
still have to like work and like it you
know and we tell yourself I mean there
are certainly are times when you okay
when you stand up you're right you're
right in many ways I've been I've been
blessed okay but I've had some hardships
myself I know we both have okay I don't
know what just stood there stood up
tonight let's say that but you know I've
had some hardship and you know I'm not
gonna quit I know but none of this room
is gonna quit well you're not gonna quit
because you used to serve tables and
you'd be in the [ __ ]
and you had three tables that just cuts
at they sat you three tables on tall
like bar tops and you're like why the
[ __ ] would you save me I just came off
break and you still made it work this is
what we do yeah we make it work I even
I've been thinking about just just I
just had this thought that you and I one
day we should collect some of our money
from this podcast it's opened up a
restaurant every slam and B slam and
just feel like see if we could make it
happen
i-i've always wanted to open a
restaurant yeah like a Filipino
breakfast restaurant
in the Bay Area you always have like the
Pepsi logo and all of that but you don't
have it here yeah had its dream of doing
that and so I'm actually not kidding I'm
down but just don't throw all the work
on me I feel like I did yeah but I want
to make he's a face on the face of yeah
I'm not gonna be like tray hose tacos
aggressive doughnuts you know how many
business is that [ __ ] guy have Danny
Trejo no but I see his top I've never
been to any of them everywhere are they
good people go there I know the tacos
all right yeah but I love breakfast
burritos as you know Papi's burritos and
there was a place that I go sometimes
you know I'll get rapped early
Toluca Lake restaurant and you know I'll
drive deep into Burbank and there's a
place called the country cottage and it
it's not a cottage and there's nothing
country about it
it's a [ __ ] hole in the wall nice
it's a little hole in the wall it's this
Asian man with tattoos on his fingers
right and then twelve Mexican dudes that
are like mid-20s and they're just making
breakfast burritos seems like people
many cuts right no but they all elves
you can tell that they're yeah I'm being
real they're all have this like a
magical lioness routine where they're
just making because everyone wants to
eat there right I'm telling you right
now my mouth is watering all right right
now I want to go tomorrow more have you
ever had tacos via Corona yes I keep
telling him and he will not go because
they close at 2:00 p.m. which is yeah I
make shut down they shut down when they
run out of tortillas I met him the first
day that's a [ __ ] best
wait the matriarch of the come sir I
just died they're open but there's
neither morning let me ask you about
tacos Caramba yep via Corona in Atwater
yeah yeah Corona you're talking they
have breakfast burritos sir yeah that's
all they do and it's great yes they're
like three dollars down they're that
good what's in it
potatoes Fiats egg and then after that
it's up to you nopales bacon steak
what is it nopales cactus I don't do
into cactus
it's so good really good very good yeah
but you know she's been singing that
place for years I've never gone I think
I wanted there I want to go to
[Music]